we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more
active we've got to get more
confrontation
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
it's harder to imagine anything more
inappropriate than a member of congress
flying in from california to inform
local leaders
not so subtly that this defendant had
better be found guilty or else there
will be big trouble
in the streets it's beyond the pale for
a sitting member of the united states
congress to look at what happened last
summer and imply
there should be some kind of a sequel
well the headlines were basically about
maxing water saturday in minnesota
familiar republicans pounce on her
comments however
it wasn't just republican critics here's
the judge
in the chauvin case today i'll give you
the congresswoman waters may have given
you something on appeal
that may result in this whole trial
being overturned i wish elected
officials would stop
talking about this case especially in a
manner that is disrespectful
to the rule of law and to the judicial
branch in our function
i think if they want to give their
opinions they should do so in a
respectful
and in a manner that is consistent with
their oath to the constitution
to respect the co-equal branch of
government
again the judge in the derek showman
case uh
the jury now has that case let's bring
in our panel bill mcgearn columnist for
the wall street journal
marla lyson national political
correspondent of national public radio
and steve hayes editor
of the dispatch steve your thoughts on
all this
well i think what maxine waters said was
deeply irresponsible and i agree with
the the judge's rebuke i mean i i think
our national leaders
in in all areas of life whether elected
officials whether republican and
democrat whether part
of the judicial branch people with a
platform should be doing everything they
can
to urge folks to follow uh to
to respect the the process here that
that's playing out in minneapolis
and to do everything they can to calm
these passions that we've seen
for maxine waters to step into the fray
and suggest
that the protesters increase their
confrontation particularly after what we
saw
on the streets whether in kenosha or
elsewhere around the country
last last summer is deeply responsible
you know mara speaker pelosi said today
she shouldn't have to apologize she
shouldn't apologize
but that was before the judge said you
may have just handed the defense
yeah something on appeal yeah i mean
look it depends on what happens with the
jury verdict and also what kind of
reaction there is
but there's no doubt that one layer of
it was this political layer where both
sides like to
focus on the most extreme member of the
opposition party
but to have a judge say that you might
have just handed
the defendant that you want to see
declared guilty
a big weapon to maybe overturn a verdict
might be a cell phone that was a whole
other layer of this
yeah bill i want to turn to foreign
policy now one of the things we talked
about with senator cotton was taiwan and
china but i didn't touch on
russia and what's happening there not
only are they building up their military
along the border with ukraine but also
you have alexei navalny who may
die take a listen we have
continued to see an increase uh
in the in the forces along the border
with ukraine and in
occupied crimea as it was before
very seriously concerning to us um and
uh we called on russia to obviously make
their intentions
uh more clear what happens to mr navalny
in
the custody of the russian government is
the responsibility
of the russian government and that they
will be held accountable by the
international community
bill what about this navalny obviously a
critic of putin and has been on the
hunger strike
right well he's not the first critic of
putin to find his life in peril later on
uh look we should hold them responsible
uh
if mr divaldi dies but the problem is
we're issuing these statements and stuff
we will not tolerate we will hold
accountable
what will we actually do
that is a challenge i mean president
biden is being challenged on many many
fronts
all these bad actors look at how he's
responding
to other challenges and i think he needs
to find at least
one and make a strong show or else i
think
his presidency is going to he's just
going to be hammered
by these very bad actors
but steve the last administration he was
a part of uh didn't do so well with red
lines
no and particularly uh with respect to
russia and crimea look i think
you know the biden administration can
say look he threw a a
brush back pitch to use a baseball
analogy with the strikes earlier on the
on the
militias um and there there was a big
statement but
i think bill is right you know you're
having these these the strong rhetoric
from the biden administration
but it's sometimes compromised by uh
mixed rhetoric
uh you know you had president biden you
had the administration
issuing sanctions last week you have
tough talk on on vladimir putin you had
president biden earlier calling him a
killer and then you have
a statement from the white house
suggesting that president biden and
president putin will meet for a summit
in the coming months well you don't meet
for a summit with somebody who's
behaving the way that vladimir putin is
is behaving these days and giving him
that kind of uh
stature lift inside russia so much of
what vladimir putin today is doing is
he's doing because he's trying to shore
up his position
inside of russia for domestic political
concerns domestic support
giving him that kind of a stature boost
at precisely this time that he's
struggling i think was a real mistake
mar isn't it the same thing with iran i
mean we are
desperately it seems trying to sit down
to negotiations to restart this nuclear
deal as the iranians are saying
you know what we are going to enrich
uranium to 60
look i think each of these foreign
problems is different
iran russia china has been more
aggressive about taiwan
but all of them are pressuring the biden
administration to do something that
proves it's credible i mean to say
they're going to be consequences you
don't have to broadcast them in advance
but if they uh if navalny dies
if russia continues to have military
incursions into
ukraine then he has to absolutely do
something
obviously we have a lot of things to
focus on in the us but these are three
big issues
overseas that we're following very
closely